("Rule Britannia")
- [Narrator] In the United Kingdom,
you may eat ducks, chickens, geese,
and, nah, not these.
(swan squawks)
They all belong to the queen, well…
- All swans in the United
Kingdom can belong to the queen,
but she mainly exercises this
right on the River Thames.
- [Narrator] Of course, sorry.
- My name's David Barber,
and I look after the swans
wherever the queen exercises
her royal prerogative right.
It's not a full-time job,
although sometimes it
feels like a full-time job.
- [Narrator] Every year
Mr. Barber runs a census
of the swans for Her Majesty,
a bit like an annual checkup.
This is called swan upping, and
he does it with a whole crew
like this guy, this guy, and this guy.
- Swan upping has taken
place since the 12th century
where swans in those days were actually
a very, very important food.
Of course, today swans
are a protected species
and no longer eaten.
We travel in six traditional rowing skiffs
from Sunbury-On-Thames all
the way up to Abingdon,
and it's about a 79-mile journey.
- What do we say when we see a swan?
- 'Ohh,
- 'old up, 'old up.’
- [David] Each family
of swans we come across,
we will circle the skiffs around them.
We will tie the wings and their legs.
We will take them ashore.
We will weigh them, measure them,
and check them for any injuries.
After we've done that, we
will put a ring on them,
and we will release them
back into the river.
- [Narrator] So if these
are the queen's swans,
where is Her Majesty for all of this?
- [David] She did come swan
upping a few year's ago,
and hopefully, she enjoyed it.
She seemed to enjoy it,
but I can't answer for the queen anyway.
I love swans, a royal bird.
People here in the United
Kingdom, they love them.
And you know, I want to make sure
that they survive for the future.
- [Narrator] All right,
gents, let's toast.
- [Dave] To the queen.
- [All] To the queen.
(electronic note)